[MUSIC]
What am I most excited about for
this year?
That's super easy.
I'm excited to have everyone back together
and in-person, and we've been waiting for
this for 18 months.
And today's the first day when
the MBA students are back, and
it's finally arrived, and it feels great.
[MUSIC]
I told the MBA class that they're
arriving at a great time.
And, of course,
part of that is they're arriving and
we're starting to get toward
the end of the pandemic.
And so the world is opening up,
and Stanford is opening up.
And all of the things that
we've been looking forward to,
we can start to do again together.
[MUSIC]
They're arriving at a time when there's
incredible change going on in the world,
in technology, in business,
and in society.
And they're arriving at Stanford at
a time when they can be right in
the middle of all of that change, and
thinking about what it is they want to
do with their careers and lives.
[MUSIC]
I think there's two big lessons
from the experience going
through the pandemic and
teaching and interacting online.
One was a positive, which was,
it was sort of revelation what
you could do virtually in
terms of getting work done,
and having classes, and keeping
even a place like Stanford running.
The other was, there's just a set of
things that happen at a business school,
at a university,
that you can't replicate with technology.
And if you think back before the pandemic,
in the case of MBA programs,
people were actually questioning, is
there value in a residential MBA program?
And if the pandemic just definitively
answered that question in a positive way?
Yes, there's just something about being
with a group of people, students, and
the faculty, and with the mix of
people that comes onto campus.
And just being in it that we still
can't do with technology, and
we can do it here on a place
like the GSB campus.
[MUSIC]
My go-to drink or
order at Coupa, it's so boring.
It's just a small black coffee.
[MUSIC]
I've been running a lot
up in the foothills.
And every time I get out in the California
foothills, it just reminds me
why I moved out to California in the first
place and why I've never left this place.
[MUSIC]